so this is a sample of osmium osmium
again is a placer precious metal
platinum group metal and this is an
audience punch which is very nicely
packaged up in this box but let's have a
look and see if we can find it
so osmium is another one of the elements
in the so called platinum group and it
is quite unusual in that it's oxide
osmium tetroxide is a stable compound
it's really quite easily evaporated it
has quite a strong smell which is
unusual for metal compounds and it can
be vaporators quite easily and it is
used in organic chemistry because if you
have compounds with double bonds between
two carbon atoms osmium tetroxide reacts
with it quite easily so here the osmium
itself okay it's a very very reactive
metal it's sealed in this glass ampule
under an inert atmosphere of argon so
that it can't oxidize the organ is very
inert and it stops
the metal reacting so here you can see
this very very dark black metal very
fine spongy type material at the bottom
of this glass foil again osmium has
played some role in my life because I
have did some of the early work in my
doctorates involved osmium compound it
was ruthenium and osmium and iron the
ruthenium compound was Orange
the osmium compound a rather fetching
pale green a pale yellow and the iron
compound the very dark green and the
osmium compound was perhaps the most
boring because it behaved in exactly the
way that was predicted so osmium reacts
with the air to form osmium tetroxide
which is a very very toxic material
makes us go blind so you have to be very
careful with storing the osmium since
then I think and I've made in my life
I made one osmium compound that nobody
had ever made before I wasn't enough to
see but I could see the absorption of
light by this pump and so I was really
quite excited
remember what was what it was in it what
do you remember what it was the compound
the compound was osmium dicarbonyl de
nitrous ale and it was interesting
because nobody had ever made this
compound before but it was similar to a
compound of iron which was quite well
known the compound of iron looked like
blood it was really quite dramatic
compound I never found out what the
color of the osmium compound was I
didn't make enough but I'm not a very
good synthetic chemist